[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome back to joke world my name is
jake and today is part two of finding
out who is the best podcast guest of all
time now just like in the first episode
i understand this is subjective i'm not
giving my own opinions i'm not reading
your comments we're using the scientific
method real math to figure out who's the
best podcast guest of all time who's the
comedian that you want on your show now
in part one we looked at mark norman
andrew schultz chrissy d brian callan
and the winner ended up being chris
delea today we're going to give dalia a
chance to defend his title against the
big dogs the heavy hitters of comedy we
got tom segura tim dillon theovan and
joey diaz to make this work we had to
find three podcasts that all five
comedians have appeared on so that's
going to be bert cast joe rogan
experience and the church of what's
happening now just like last time the
scores will be calculated by the total
amount of views an episode gets divided
by the total amount of subscribers that
podcast has so for example let's say tom
segura went on the joe rogan experience
and got 5 million views on that episode
we'd take that 5 million views divided
by the 11.9 million subscribers joe
rogan has and that gives you a total
score of 0.42 for tom segura uh i
promise this will make a lot more sense
once we get into the video it's very
simple and easy to follow along if
you're like this seems dumb i just want
to see compilations come back this
weekend we're doing part two of tim
dillon's top 10 rants but if you really
like stand up you really like podcasting
you're a really big fan of these guys i
guarantee that you'll love this video so
let's just watch without further ado
let's get into it we'll start off with
birdcast
burke pricer has 834 000 subscribers on
youtube we'll start off with the
defending champ crystal leah he appeared
on birdcast three years ago episode 306
that had 765 thousand views giving
crystallia a total burqa score of 0.91 i
always say that brian callan and i say
we we say oh yeah we do stand up and you
want to have a conversation
do you know what i mean like oh i do
stand up
what the [ __ ] are we going to talk about
yeah at a party like what you know what
i mean like
like we do
our favorite version of that on stage
all the time oh yeah i used to my wife
my wife gets exhausted at me because i
go to a dinner party yeah and someone
will go uh you know i did something
interesting the other day yeah my wife
said i don't know here we go i know i
should always preface this guy's bert
you they don't know you yeah so just let
it be they don't need to know you yeah
i'll [ __ ] trump i i will i am
insufferable at a dinner party tim
dillon was also on the show three years
ago he was episode 300 that had 156 000
views giving tim dillon a bert cast
score of 0.18 alex jones thing's [ __ ]
it's it's wild it's wild here's the
thing i don't
i don't really listen to infowars yeah
but i do listen to when he's on roads
again i gotta be honest with you he's
the most entertaining person
in the world i mean i hate listen is it
bad sure am i gonna get in trouble for
saying this yes does he incite violence
maybe the point i'm making okay
the point the point i'm making is purely
forget morals forget any of this take
yourself back to smoking weed in the
back of a car in 11th grade yeah when
you were just like things were just
funny or they weren't they were just
entertaining they weren't you either
watched it and went what the [ __ ] is
this
i heard alex jones okay
go on a rant
about
demons like literal demons
for 20 minutes
20 minutes hard about
demons
and let me tell you right now
i and he started a show night and he was
like this goes ladies and gentlemen he
goes we are bracing this first words out
of his mouth he goes ladies and
gentlemen we are bracing for
thermonuclear war
and i'm like how do you how do you not
yeah how do you not lay how do you not
be entertained i mean dude him and i
think him rogan and eddie bravo amazing
one of the best podcasts and i'm just
like i gotta start listening to [ __ ] and
i turn it on i was like what the [ __ ]
hey this is what he does for a living
joy diaz's best episode was four years
ago episode 241 he had 691 thousand
views on that giving him a bert cast
score of 0.82
a little something for the for the
podcast
a little protein
there you go a little something for the
podcast
that's some onions i had at lunch tom
segura appeared on episode 100 of
bertcast and then also with dave attell
on episode 237 now episode 100 was not
fully uploaded to youtube so we're just
going to go with his dave tell
appearance number 237 that was a score
of 0.74
but uh that was nice you but the part
you're going to really love so their
gopro hero4 blacks guess what they're
called what
that one's wesley snipes
[Music]
that one's kimbo slice
and that's james winston
he's so black
not skin tone just behaviorally
jameis winston i can't decide whether i
really [ __ ] love the guy like if he's
a forrest gump of football or if he is
he's not the forest cup
and last but not least the rat king theo
van appeared on burkas six years ago
episode number 140 he had 229 thousand
views on that episode giving him a bert
cast score of 0.27 i was a fan of you on
road rules yeah i was a re i thought you
should be a comic when i first saw you
on road remember me telling you that
story yeah were you telling me your wife
thought i was cute yeah
she definitely thought you were not
offense that i didn't hear what you said
but i mean like
you know i was a
22 year old kid i was like ah no um
that's more exciting well that does it
for round one let's check in the
leaderboard so far crystal lee is
defending his title with 0.91 joey diaz
right behind him at 0.82 tom segura is
middling right now at 0.74 theo's a
little behind at 0.27 i expect him to
pick it up and then tim dillon rounding
us out as the caboose at 0.18 i always
expect to see him picking it up in the
next episode
hello freak [ __ ] the joe rogan
experience i'm not sure if all of you
have heard of it it's more of a niche
smaller low-key podcast there's 11.9
million subscribers obviously all five
of these communities have been on jre
many many times but with the recent
spotify thing and you know episodes
being pulled down by tim dillon and joey
diaz especially and i guess tom segura's
episodes have been pulled down so if
chris isn't all five of these people
have had episodes pulled off of spotify
off of their joe rogan appearances so
we're just gonna go based on what full
episodes are still up on youtube and the
views off of those real quick i'm not
sure if you noticed this new chair
behind me but i want to give a quick
shout out to the people at ewin racing
for sending me this beast i got my old
shirt from amazon and it broke after
about a month of use just clean in half
but this ewing chair can hold up to 550
pounds so i never have to worry about
that again i can gain as much weight as
i want and not have to worry about
getting any new chairs i mean look how
wide the seat is i can fit a whole
nother person next to me these things
flip out
huge wide cushion you could fit so many
people in this chair my favorite part is
the neck and the back pillows it makes
me want to sleep in this thing so that's
about it if you want this chair go check
out the link in the description for 20
off now back to the video crystalia's
best joe rogan episode was five years
ago episode 980 he had 2.6 million views
for a total score of 0.21 like game of
thrones i watch it for four seasons i
know you love that [ __ ] show
i know but i just you know what it's not
my stylish show man why are you saying i
mean awesome no it is awesome no it is
awesome but it's only awesome it's like
breaking bad the reason why i love
breaking bad the reason why sopranos i
love it so much is because there's
[ __ ] humor in it man there's humor in
it sometimes there is
zero humor in game of thrones true and i
get that that's a style but i just can't
be sucked into something for five six
seasons where nobody trips
where nobody is just like awkward at a
table
and they're just talking about dragons
in the most serious [ __ ] way yeah but
there's real dragons back then
tim dillon's best still standing episode
took place a year ago episode 1525 that
had 7.5 million views giving tim dillon
the total jre score of 0.63 just polos
just like this just ill-fitting polos
yeah ill-fitting polos for the american
racists
polos are a weird choice pier like why
is it that that is like the only thing i
wear for dorks wear you know what it is
i i i've always wanted to look like i've
had money and i've never looked like it
and there's a type of guy that's from a
lot of them live in new york or long
island or boston by the way yes izod yes
and they wear these [ __ ] polos and
they have no [ __ ] money and that's
the kind of guy that i am where it's
like i always want to look but they're
always sunburned and they've always got
like an ill-fitting thing like the
collars like these collars all [ __ ] up
because i tumble dry it in the wash like
an animal
i look like like a golf pro who's failed
at everything and his wife laughed like
john daly's brother yeah yeah i mean but
that's the look and when you have the
look you just honor the look joey diaz
might be one of the most legendary jre
guests of all time i know that's how i
found out about joey diaz was on this
show and a lot of these other guys too
his best episode though was three years
ago episode 1140 that had 14 million
views giving joey diaz a total jre score
of 1.17 he had a dog and when it was it
was too cold he just let the dog [ __ ]
downstairs
and there was like 20 pieces of little
rolled up [ __ ] that had been you know
like when the the juice goes out of them
they just roll up what's those things
that you use as
organ what are those accordions
accordions it was like a piece of [ __ ]
shrinks like an accordion when the
moisture goes out of it it really does
so if you take a [ __ ] that's this big
right and you put it in a box come back
a week later it's like this big how do i
know that because i did it to a guy in
prison i took a [ __ ] in a welfare box
one time you know oh jesus you know the
boxes of cheese where the cheese comes
in american cheese yes this dude had
long hair and would always try to play
me like he was with the biker dudes in
the box for him but he played he wore he
lived in the key worked in the kitchen
he forgot i ran the kitchen and it was
all me and black dudes so one day i got
one of the welfare cheese boxes and i
took like a 22 24 inch it looked like a
lizard
it just it was just a long
like you know thin at the end like one
of those things that paper like a snail
that's what it looks like a long brown
snail
and i fit it perfectly into this cheese
box
and i took a flag on the american flag
like from the cheese and i put it on top
and i put it in this drawer
and every night
and he had the first bunk
on the way out so everybody had to walk
back and all the black guys would open
the door and go god damn it smells like
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] and he kept
saying i know it does i don't know why
it smells like [ __ ] in here and after
like a month when they won this draw
everybody kept saying man it smells like
[ __ ] in here he went in this drawer
opened it up and he found this box
he opened it up and i never forget him
knocking on my bunk going i'm going to
find out who did this to me like what
they do to you
and he goes look at this like what is it
and i knew it was [ __ ]
but it had shrunken down from the 24
inches
to like six little inches
it just shrunk down when all the
moisture goes out tom seguro is another
joe rogan experience og his best episode
came three years ago episode 1147 that
had 5.2 million views giving tom segura
a jre score of zero point four three
like wait lasagna or something like that
i'm not talking to nobody about nothing
no if you talk to me i i don't know what
i'm saying i'm just going what yeah what
are we talking about brain shuts down
and i start to go like
like
those types of burps the gut
starts to like push out more and then
i'll start ripping crazy farts
like i farted christina made this pasta
dish and last night i farted so crazy
she goes do you even respect me anymore
like i was like yeah but i mean this is
what's going on right now
this happens this is marriage
theovan's also been on the show multiple
times he actually credits his
appearances on the joe rogan experience
for the reason why he wanted to start
his own podcast so that's pretty cool
for all of us this past weekend fans uh
his best episode was three years ago
episode one two two five that had 6.5
million views giving theovan a total jre
score of 0.54 oh that's a so right yeah
that's uh
uh soas massager isn't that great so
awesome yeah that's this muscle in here
oh i'm gonna come on that thing i think
it feels [ __ ] good bro i'm sorry bro
that thing feels good you are so horny
today dude i had to drive it's like 20
minute drive over here oh that gets you
money driving nothing like driving dude
i'll say this things that get me erect
these days driving
being on planes
you know that
uh bumpy roads
killing those bumpy road boners
dude those are real you asked me one
time remember they had a lady uh i fell
i got an erection on a plane and she got
pissed she told the
she told the flight attendant to get me
a blanket yeah well did you have it out
no i was asleep and it was in my pants
it was in your pants and she saw it
somehow yeah she saw my pants because i
wear lean pants lean pants or you know i
wasn't wearing like a
fat canvas or anything you know
textiles yeah
carpet
all right that does round two let's
check the leaderboard we got a new
favorite with joey diaz at 1.99 tom in
second place with 1.17 crystalia
middling and then theo and tim dillon
are tied for last at 0.81 and finally
the church of what's happening now we're
eating we're smoking we're living we're
breathing you bad [ __ ] at the
church it's a church of what's happening
now what what
uh
that was [ __ ] dope joey
what why we laughed
black people
chinese
joey diaz has 796 000 subs on youtube
we'll start with the leah again his
first appearance was four years ago
episode 518. he had 344 000 views on
that episode giving him a total church
of what's happening now score of 0.43
yeah it's [ __ ] weird the people you
see up there oh oh oh one time i got off
stage and this dude with a cast on is
like bro you're [ __ ] hilarious are
you [ __ ] i'm like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm like thanks man and i'm
looking at shyla buff
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm like what's up bro
thanks
my attitude changed such a [ __ ] fake
hollywood moment but i'm like get this
[ __ ] guy here oh you're in
transformers what's up tim dylan was on
the podcast two years ago episode 759 he
racked up 408 000 views giving him a
church score of 0.51 when did you start
doing comments 2010 what made you get up
what made me do it the first time i was
in the mortgage business and
uh
in 2000 knowledge educated uh no dropped
at a community college uh to do percocet
and sell subprime mortgages in long
island which i still believe is the what
i will return to
i believe stand-up is a sabbatical from
my true calling which is to work in a
strip mall
uh and have great lunches serious
lunches some score has been in the
church of what's happening now a bunch
of times sometimes he's by himself
sometimes he's with bert but his best
episode was 537 it was a solo episode
four years ago he had 647 000 views
which gives tom segura a church of
what's happening now score of 0.81 that
reminds me i told you okay that reminds
me of something you said one time i had
no idea what you meant you said
you go
black people eat to talk
and i go what
and you said i'm serious like they go
that's right to eat to talk and you said
if somebody [ __ ] talks while i'm
eating i'm gonna [ __ ] stab him in the
neck but you had a whole rant i don't
know if you if you even remember saying
this a whole rant about eating to talk
it had never heard anything like it in
my life
it drives me [ __ ] crazy
he knows the exact story
he knows why you know the exact trend
you know you know what's going on
where or you know
i don't know what he was talking about
do you know what i'm talking about or
not i don't know
yes neither then now theo is probably
the best the church of what's happening
now guest of all time every time that he
shows up it's huge numbers but if you're
a fan of theovan if you're a fan of joey
diaz and if you're a fan of the church
then you know what episode we're talking
about here happened five years ago the
magic mushroom episode it was number 383
him joey diaz lisa they're all trip and
shrooms it's one of the best pieces of
entertainment on the internet one of the
best podcasts in any category not just
comedy of all time this got two million
views which gives theo van a huge church
score of 2.51 ever since i've been with
him i just get unlocked i've never had i
never had skin issues and now i get
styes
if i look at a hot tub
trust me
that's why i sleep on my stomach i was
trying to sleep on your stomach i do
like a [ __ ] dead animal yeah i'm like
armadillo yeah or on my side i'm or
mostly either my stomach or my size
christ do your arms touch the ground
yeah of course how do you even do that
bro
you have no idea dog right who's
sleeping on your stomach face down no
yeah oh face to the side i have pillows
yeah oh face to the side jesus christ
i'll tell you slip face down maybe i
have like a massage table in my bedroom
no but i just
dude you're a [ __ ] unreal league i
figured what we were talking about they
should have dolls they should have to
leave cyan dolls bro
they're indestructible dude obviously
joey diaz can't be a guest on his own
show it was hard to find you know three
different podcasts that all five of
these comedians had been on so we're
gonna have to get creative here towards
the end and we're gonna use joey diaz's
tiger belly appearance uh for his final
score so he appeared on the show three
years ago it was tiger belly 143. he had
1.4 million views which gives him a
massive score of 2.07
and he's already in the lead so this is
going to be huge i met a woman at
flappers one night just very casually in
the back she was like uh
she did something for flappers
and i didn't and i
i'm no [ __ ] man
come on you looking great what am i
going to do with a girl
oh man i got 55 year old nuts they look
like they're 55.
for a young girl to suck them i wouldn't
get no satisfaction on it i'm just
[ __ ] somebody's world up yeah
i'm just [ __ ] somebody's worldwide
yeah it's like one time rogan asked me
he goes did you ever have a girlfriend
that committed suicide no but if anybody
sucked my dick i'd kill myself
that brings us to the final standings so
without further ado in fifth place with
a score of 1.32
tim dillon in fourth place with a score
of 1.55
no longer the defending champ ladies and
gentlemen chris delia the bronze
medalist in third place with a score of
1.98 tommy buns tom segura the second
place finisher blew the first three
people out of the water with a score of
3.32 the silver medalist theo vaughn and
that means with a score of 4.06 the new
undisputed greatest podcast guest of all
time the one and only joey coco diaz
get up [ __ ] it's all over
congratulations to joey diaz and
everyone else who was part of this
obviously it's impossible to really say
who the greatest podcast guest of all
time is but this is a fun video to make
we'll definitely do a part three so
comment who you'd like to see in that
make sure that you're following us on
instagram to get your free joke world
stickers uh shout out to everyone who's
dm'd us and gotten these and put them up
everywhere it's awesome to see um and so
just make sure you're doing that the
link is in the bio and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you